although the driver is often to blame
for a crash an alert passenger could
help prevent it an important message
during National passenger Safety Week
Madison Kimbrough joins us live near a
memorial I should say a memorable spot
in North Las Vegas that claimed the
lives of multiple people
we're here on Cheyenne and commerce and
it's hard to believe that it's been
almost a year since that horrific crash
occurred killing nine people including a
family of seven and tonight we hear from
those who have experienced deadly
crashes and how a passenger can make the
difference between life and death
had she been awake
would she have told her friend to slow
down
would she had made sure that her friend
wasn't on the phone and texting Tina
Lavoy talking about her daughter Hillary
who was writing in the passenger seat
when her friend lost control of the car
and crashed the 18 year old died on
impact as a passenger as a driver you
need to be secure in your in your car
and make sure you're paying attention to
your surroundings that's the message
during National passenger Safety Week be
present be alert even when you're not
the one driving the numbers are going up
they're not going down and it occurred
to me that we need to take another look
at how we deal with crash prevention
Candace Lightner founder of we save
lives and Mothers Against Drunk Driving
teamed up with the National Road Safety
Foundation to create this week we need
to get the word out the passengers have
power they can save lives they can save
their life they can save the life of the
driver and in turn save the lives of all
the people on the roads the Department
of Public Safety reports Clark County
had 240 six fatalities last year that's
up by about 4.2 percent from the
previous year and for Lavoy her daughter
was more than a statistic having that
second set of eyes in that seat next to
you is so important
there will be a tree dedication ceremony
held at Craig Ranch Park this Sunday
honoring the lives lost in the crash
that happened here on Cheyenne and
commerce now the sole survivor of that
crash is actually hosting the event it's
open to the public reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now